herr präsident lieber
herr bundespräsident
herr bundeskanzler
herr präsident des bundesrates
der präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes
exzellenzen
sehr geehrte frau auerbacher liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
verehrte gäste
vor 80 jahren am 20 januar
1942 kamen in einer villa am wannsee
15 hochrangige staatsbeamte und ns
parteifunktionäre zusammen das thema der
besprechung lautete die endlösung der
judenfrage
allen anwesenden war klar was damit
gemeint war
der massenmord war längst im gange es
ging darum ihn zu systematisieren zu
beschleunigen und auf ganz europa
auszudehnen auf 11 millionen jüdinnen
und juden
einwände erhob keiner der beteiligten
wir gedenken der opfer der
nationalsozialistischen verbrechen
der ermordeten jüdinnen und juden der
toten der sinti und roma der opfer der
slawischen völkern wir gedenken der
millionen menschen die verfolgt beraubt
gedemütigt entrechtet gequält und dem
tode preisgegeben wurden weil sie anders
dachten an das glaubten an das liebten
oder weil ihr leben den
nationalsozialisten als unwert galt die
wannseekonferenz steht für ein staat in
dem unrecht zu recht wurde für einen
staat der das verbrechen plante
organisierte und verwaltete dieser staat
wurde von menschen getragen
menschen die zu mördern und
helfershelfern wurden heute ist deswegen
auch ein tag der scham für das was
frühere generationen deutschland getan
haben
die die täter nie gezeigt haben viel zu
wenige mussten sich vor gericht
verantworten
viel zu viele sind mit strafen
davongekommen die einer verhöhnung der
opfer gleichkam auch teilnehmer der
wannsee-konferenz
sehr geehrte frau auerbacher sie stehen
vor uns als zeuge in einer zeit die für
die allermeisten längst geschichte ist
weit weg und völlig unvorstellbar
als sie sieben jahre alt waren sind sie
mit ihren eltern ins kz theresienstadt
deportiert worden es war der tag an dem
ihre kindheit endete
etwa anderthalb millionen jüdische
kinder sind im holocaust umgekommen sie
schreiben in einem ihrer bücher dass sie
diese drei millionen augen auf sich
spüren
sie bitten darum sie nicht zu vergessen
sie bitten
sie die bitte diese bitte ist ihnen zur
berufung geworden
in den vergangenen jahren und
jahrzehnten haben sie unzähligen
menschen ihre geschichte erzählt vor
allem kindern und jugendlichen damit
diese nicht vergessen
ich danke ihnen
dass sie ihre anreise aus new york die
nicht leicht war insbesondere unter den
schweren bedingungen der pandemie auf
sich genommen haben um heute zu uns zu
sprechen und ihre geschichte zu erzählen
das ist uns eine große ehre
[Applaus]
als inge auerbacher familie den
sogenannten abwanderungs befehl erhielt
war ihr geburtsort kippenheim bereits
wie es im nazi jargon hieß jugendfrei
fast alle badischen fischen und
saarländischen juden waren im oktober
1940 ins lager groß im unbesetzten teil
frankreichs verschleppt worden es
handelte sich um eine der ersten
massendeportationen deutscher jüdinnen
und juden all das fand am hellichten tag
statt und es lief wie die
verantwortlichen berichteten
größtenteils ohne zwischenfälle ab
die wieder hergerichtete synagoge in
kippenheim ist heute ein gedenk und
begegnungsstätte getragen von
ehrenamtlichen tätigen bürgerinnen und
bürgern
einem engagierten verein ist es auch zu
verdanken dass das haus von inge lauras
großeltern in jedem hausen erhalten
wurde und heute teil eines erinnerungs
weges an das einstige jüdische leben in
göppingen ist ich begrüße
stellvertretend für diese vielfältige
lokales engagement den oberbürgermeister
von göppingen herrn alex meier
[Applaus]
unsere gedenk und erinnerungskultur ist
auf initiativen wie diese angewiesen sie
lebt von engagierten bürgerinnen und
bürgern von vereinen die sich um
erinnerungsorte kümmern von schülerinnen
und schülern die sich auf spurensuche
begeben
erinnerungskultur lässt sich nicht von
oben verordnen sie erschöpft sich nicht
in staatlichen ritualen wie diesem
alljährlichen gedenkakt jedenfalls nicht
in einer freiheitlichen gesellschaft
die erinnerung wandelt sich immer
weniger zeitzeugen können aus eigenem
erleben berichten immer mehr menschen
bei uns haben keine deutsche vorfahren
die deutsche schreckens geschichte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts ist nicht ihre
das macht die arbeit von schulen
gedenkstätten und museen um so wichtiger
unsere von vielen beachtete gedenkkultur
bleibt nur lebendig wenn wir immer
wieder von neuen fragen an die
geschichte stellen und nach antworten
suchen das gilt gerade für junge
menschen
es bedeutet auch andere blickwinkel
zuzulassen
bezugspunkte zu den geschichten anderer
zu debattieren solange wir das
angemessen sensibel
verantwortungsbewusst und respektvoll
tun um so trauriger macht es mich dass
wir die bunten jugendbegegnungen des
deutschen bundestages pandemie bedingt
verschieben mussten selbstverständlich
werden wir die jugendbegegnungen so
schnell wie möglich nachholen sie bringt
junge leute aus unterschiedlichen
ländern mit vielfältigen
lebensgeschichten und erfahrungen zu
sammeln und
sie 11 die überzeugung dass das was war
sich niemals wiederholen darf
antisemitismus
menschenfeindlichkeit und rassismus
haben in unserer gesellschaft keinen
platz weder in der gegenwart noch in der
zukunft
unser land trägt eine besondere
verantwortung der völkermord an den
juden europas ist ein deutsches
verbrechen aber
es ist zugleich eine vergangenheit die
alle angeht nicht nur deutsche nicht nur
juden
deshalb beteiligt sich der bundestag
zusammen mit anderen europäischen
parlamenten an der gedenk kampagne we
remember in den sozialen medien
gemeinsam mit vielen anderen weltweit
setzen wir ein zeichen zur erinnerung an
den holocaust gegen fremdenfeindlichkeit
und judenhass aber zeichen setzen
alleine reicht nicht ich begrüße den
präsidenten der knesset herrn micheletti
wir freuen uns dass sie bei uns sind ihr
besuch unterstreicht die engen
besonderen beziehungen zwischen den
parlamenten unserer länder 70 jahre
nachdem konrad adenauer und ben doriot
das luxemburger abkommen unterzeichneten
wiedergutmachung für etwas das nicht
wieder gutzumachen ist
die aussöhnung zwischen deutschland und
israel erscheint im rückblick wie ein
wunder ein wertvolles geschenk das es zu
pflegen gilt
deutschland und israel sind nicht in
allem einer meinung aber dennoch ware
partner wie der damalige israelische
staatspräsident will ihn vor zwei jahren
hier an dieser stelle unterstrich
uns ein nicht zuletzt gemeinsame werte
für die wir einstehen und auch als lehre
aus der geschichte das gilt besonders
für den kampf des antisemitismus
wir politik und gesellschaft führen
diesen kampf schon lange wir haben
expertenkommission und antisemitismus
beauftragte eingesetzt wir haben
zahlreiche zivilgesellschaftliche
initiativen und vereine wir haben das
strafrecht verschärft wir mahnen und
bekunden unmissverständlich
antisemitismus ist nicht hinnehmbar
punkt
egal wie er sich äußern
egal wo er herkommt nie wieder sollen
sich antijüdische stereotype und
vorurteile breit machen können nie
wieder sollen jüdinnen und juden
herhalten müssen für die übel der welt
nie wieder soll antisemitismus den boden
bereiten für ausgrenzung hass und
vernichtungs war
auch diese gedenkstunde ist teil unseres
engagement
denn wir erinnern um jeder gefahr der
wiederholung entgegenzuwirken so sagt es
die proklamation zum tag des gedenkens
aber erinnern und gedenken macht nicht
immun gegen antisemitismus
es schützt nicht vor rassismus und
rechtsextremismus
sie haben den mörderischen terror durch
den nsu nicht verhindert nicht den
antisemitischen anschlag von halle nicht
die rechtsextremen morde von hanau das
wissen um die geschichte hat nicht
verhindert dass ein drittel der
deutschen bevölkerung meint die juden
hätten vielleicht doch zu großen
einfluss das 70 prozent ganz oder
teilweise finden die israelische politik
im nahen osten sei zitat genauso schlimm
wie die politik der nazis im zweiten
weltkrieg
und dass die pandemie auf ohnehin
grassierenden judenhass wie ein
brandbeschleuniger wird der
antisemitismus ist da er findet sich
nicht nur am äußersten rand nicht nur
bei dem ewig unbelehrbaren und ein paar
antisemitischen trollen im netz er ist
ein problem unserer gesellschaft der
ganzen gesellschaft der antisemitismus
ist mitten unter uns
[Applaus]
wir müssen uns ehrlich befragen auch
jenen die sich selbst für überzeugte
anti anti semiten halten wie frei sind
wir wirklich von antijüdischen klischees
gelingt es uns immer jüdinnen und juden
nicht für ihr für die israelische
politik in haftung zu nehmen sind wir
aus falsch verstandener toleranz zu
nachgiebig gegenüber einem
antisemitismus den mancher zugewanderter
aus ihrer alten heimat mitgebracht haben
und nehmen wir eigentlich war das
vielschichtige jüdische leben dass es
zum glück wieder gibt in deutschland die
vielfalt einer jüdischen gegenwart die
jüdische deutsche und deutsche juden
kennt zu der orthodoxe und liberale
gehören die junge israelis ebenso
umfasst wie jüdische familien aus der
ehemaligen sowjetunion denn die juden
gibt es nicht genauso wenig wie es die
deutschen gibt oder die flüchtlinge oder
die muslime im übrigen wer gegen muslime
und ihren glauben hetzt der macht sich
als freund des judentums unglaubwürdig
wer menschen bei uns ablehnt weil sie
anders sind oder einfach weil sie nicht
schon immer hier waren der sollte das
wort freiheit nicht im grunde für
die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
jedes menschen die lehren aus der
geschichte haben unsere verfassung
geprägt wir wissen aus erfahrung freie
gesellschaften bleiben aus dem inneren
heraus verwundbar
deshalb braucht es den mut zur in
toleranz denen gegenüber die die
demokratie gebrauchen wollen um sie
umzubringen das sind nicht meine worte
das hat carlo schmid so drastisch
formuliert als ein vater des
grundgesetzes
unsere freiheitliche demokratie muss
sich wappnen gegenüber jenen die die
demokratie beschwören aber nur ihre
eigene freiheit meinen die toleranz für
sich einfordern aber für pluralismus nur
verachtung übrig haben die lügen
verbreiten um zu verunsichern die zu
hass und gewalt anstacheln um sich im
nachhinein mit empörter geste zu
distanzieren
die mehrheit in diesem land hat dafür
nichts übrig sie lässt sich nicht zum
hass verführen sie wählt und streitet
demokratisch und das gerne
leidenschaftlich auch erbittert
gegenüber den anderen brauchen wir mehr
mut zur intoleranz
den entschlossenen einsatz aller mittel
die die wehrhafte demokratie kennt wenn
rechtsextremisten
geschichtsrevisionisten und völkisch
nationale wahlerfolge feiern dann ist
das kein alarmzeichen dann ist es
allerhöchste zeit zu handeln
dann ist es höchste zeit zusammen zu
stehen um die werte und institutionen
unserer freien demokratischen
gesellschaft zu beschützen denn die
demokratie trägt kein ewigkeit siegel
sie ist angewiesen auf bürgerinnen und
bürger die sie schätzen und mit leben
erfüllen auch daran erinnern uns dieser
tag und die deutsche geschichte von uns
allen hängt es ab
sehr geehrte damen und herren im
mörderischen deutschen rassen waren ist
eine vielfältige über jahrhunderte
gewachsene kultur untergegangen europa
ist ärmer geworden wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen intellektuelle
künstlerinnen und künstler wurden
vertrieben ging ins exil kam ums leben
einer von ihnen ist der prager komponist
hans krása seine kinderoper brundibár
missbrauchten die nazis für ihre
propaganda im kz theresienstadt
dort hat hans krása auch das
streichertrio geschrieben dass wir
gleich hören werden er starb 1944 in
auschwitz
ich danke den musikerinnen und musikern
der prager opernhäuser dem kantor hewitt
so rick und ebenso allen künstlerinnen
und künstlern die an dieser gedenkstunde
mitwirken nach dem musikstück
nach dem musikstück haben sie liebt frau
erbacher das wort herzlichen dank
[Applaus]